you say here i was the last off last one
off the ship when they dumped us out too
far we marched off the ramp into the
water and all walked in a line i made my
way into the icy water that reached up
to my chin holding my rifle over my head
but i wasn't thinking about the water's
temperature i just wanted to get through
it alive the section of shore i landed
on was known as easy red we were
supposed to be able to walk through the
surf and find bomb holes which would be
shelters for us the air corps totally
missed omaha beach so there was no
protection for us
those beaches were all mined
i would find out later in life that
there were millions of mines on that
beach if you stepped on one of those
babies it was a quick trip to heaven i
was more afraid of stepping on a mine
than being shot at i ran toward the
cliffs making sure to step in the same
footprints as the man in front of me
made
what in the hell am i doing here
the thought pounded in my head as i
dodged bullets determined to stay
focused on reaching the safety of the
cliffs
how did a simple farm boy from minnesota
land on omaha beach on d-day
machine guns were firing in all
directions with bodies everywhere those
mg 42 machine guns shot 1200 to 1500
rounds per minute
i ran and dodged finally making my way
to a sand berm
the bullets were blasting off the berm
as i ducked into it i wasn't going to
get out of that hole no matter what
i smoked at that time and i had my
cigarettes in this plastic bag so they
wouldn't get wet unfortunately i didn't
have a match
i remember then that i started shaking
before that moment i had felt no fear
i turned to my left and left and saw a
soldier lying down with his back toward
me
i called out hey buddy do you have a
match
then i noticed there was no head
underneath the helmet
that got me moving jake move i told
myself
i got up and dashed for the bottom of
the cliff wall about 200 yards away i
remember saying to myself jake what the
hell are you doing here you're running
for your life so nobody can shoot you
but everybody can shoot at you
i only weighed 120 pounds soaking wet so
that was an advantage since it's hard to
shoot at a toothpick
after what seemed like an eternity
i made it to the cliff wall where i was
safe
from what i've read over 2500 died at
omaha beach that day